selena gomez just hit the gym with her
grandpa
and his fitness routine has her totally
shook
i am so excited the 29 year old triple
threat took to tick tock on sunday to
share
this clip from their sweat sesh
alongside the caption quote
my 73 year old grandfather had to prove
a point
yeah if the point he's trying to prove
is that he's more fit than
literally any of us consider us
convinced
i love it as for selena she's quickly
becoming a tick-tock pro
and just last month the lose you to love
me singer got fans talking after she
posted
this clip so you're telling me that you
can read his astrological birth chart
but you can't read the red flags
says the short clip has over 4 million
likes
and her followers sprinted to the
comments to weigh in
theorizing the post was about her ex
justin bieber
okay so selena isn't confirming or
denying all that
but the posts do come just before her
big return to acting
i got in the elevator with these two
weirdos then tim
got in the elevator
approximately 12 minutes from now i will
be murdered
selena stars in the upcoming hulu series
only the murders in the building
alongside steve martin and martin short
hey
steve should people watch our show
[Laughter]
selena made headlines after a press
conference last week where she was asked
about her experience
making the upcoming murder mystery show
and how it compared to her past work
selena who starred on disney's wizards
of waverly place from 2007 to 2012
explained quote i signed my life away to
disney at a very young age
and i didn't know what i was doing did
you guys know that there's a school on
board
and there's a 24-hour pizza bar
she also praised her new project for its
quote level of sophistication
adding that when she was a kid she was
quote just running around
on set it's really nice to be back on tv
and it's nice to be cast as my actual
age which
never happens i can't stop thinking
about them neither can i
we should do our own true crime podcast
we're going to go down there and look
around for clues you want to come
do i want to break into a dead guy's
apartment and go through all
sounds like an afternoon only the
murders in the building drops on august
31st
so until then we'll just be here
watching selena
and her grandpa slay on tick tock
you